the plan for today is what I'm going to
talk about is the topic of convolutional
neural networks so essentially it's
actually quite a lot of content in this
lecture of different things that's good
to know about since essentially this is
going to be learn about convolutional
neural networks in one large bite for
NLP so bid on announcements explain the
general idea of convolutional neural
networks and then for quite a bit of it
I'm want to go through in sort of some
detail two particular papers that made
use of convolutional neural networks for
text classification sentence
classification tasks the first is are
sort of a pretty simple CNN that was
done in 2014 and then the second one is
a way more complex CNN there was done
much more recently in 2017 okay but
first a couple of announcements firstly
the last reminder on the mid-quarter
feedback survey so tons of you have done
this already thank you thank you very
much but if you still be putting it off
till the very last minute tonight at
midnight is your last chance to fill in
the mid-quarter survey to get your to
give us feedback and to get your half a
point okay and then the other thing that
you should be thinking about and I know
lots of you are thinking about since I
spent three hours talking to people
yesterday is about final projects and so
make sure you've got some plans from
that in place for 4:00 p.m. 4:30 p.m.
Thursday I mean in particular as we've
discussed you're part of what you're
meant to do this year is to have found
some research paper have read it and
have a summary and thoughts as to how it
can inform your work and then just make
sure you have in your calendars the
final project poster session for CS 224
in which is going to be in the evening
of Wednesday March 20th and we're
holding it at the Alumni Center okay one
more sort of announcement or just
general
stuff to cogitate so we're now
officially in the second half of the
class congratulations
and you know there are sort of still a
few things that we want to teach you
that a sort of basics and actually
convolutional neural networks is one of
them
but I mean nevertheless in the second
half of the class I mean things start to
change and we're hoping to much more
prepare you for being real deep learning
NLP researchers or practitioners and so
what does that mean concretely well the
lectures start to be less giving every
detail of how to build a very basic
thing and more giving you some ideas to
sort of some of the work that's been
done in different areas and so the
extent that there's something of
interest or relate relevant to a project
or things like that the hope is that
well you can take some initiative to
find out more about some of the things
that are being talked about also would
really welcome any questions about
things that people would want to know
more about and the other thing that you
should know about deep learning is that
once we get past the fundamentals a lot
of the stuff we teach it's just isn't
really known science or things that
people are sure of that you know most of
what I'm teaching in the second half of
the course is pretty much what people
think is good practice in 2019 but you
know the fact of the matter is what
people think is good practice and deep
learning has been changing really
rapidly so if you go back even two years
or definitely if you go back four years
right they're just a lot of different
things that people used to believe and
now people have some different ideas as
to what works best and it's perfectly
clear that come 2021 or 2023 there'll be
some different ideas again as to what
people think is best so you sort of just
have to accept that this is a nascent
rapidly emerging field and it's good to
understand the fundamentals and how
things fit together but after that quite
a bit of the knowledge is this is what
people think is good at the moment and
it keeps evolving over time and
if you want to stay in the field of
doing things with deep learning you kind
of sort of have to keep up with how it
changes
it's called lifelong learning these days
it's a very trendy concept and so as
well as the lectures this is also true
for the assignments and you know we've
been trying to make the assignments so
that they started off very introductory
and gradually started to use less
scaffolding and we're going to hope to
continue that with a sort of less
hand-holding in assignment five and you
know I guess what we're hoping to do is
prepare you both for the final project
and for real-life I guess I was making
an analogy this morning
comparing this to the sort of intro CS
sequence or when there's CS 106 a and B
that have tons of scaffolding and then
as CS 107 you're meant to learn how to
diagnose and solve problems for yourself
in a debugger that it's kind of the same
for neural networks that you know for
the early assignments you know we've
given you every bit of hand-holding of
here all of these tests to make sure
every little bit of it is okay and
here's exactly how to structure things
but you know in the real world you're
only going to be able to build and use
neural networks if you can figure out
why they're not working and what you
have to change to make them work and you
know the truth is as I talked a bit
about last week you know that's often
well more than half of the job that it
seems easy enough to stick down here's
my neural net and the pieces that make
sense to me and then you can spend the
remaining 80% at the time scratching
your head and wondering why it doesn't
actually work well and how you could
change it to make it to work well so I
confess that debugging neural Nets can
often be hard but you know the goal is
that you should actually learn something
about doing it and that's kind of one of
the learning goals of the course when it
comes down to it find a little
advertisement if you feel like you'd
like to read a book just out this week
there's a new book on natural language
processing with pay torch by della prowl
and Brian McMahon Delap actually lives
in San Francisco
so if you want you can buy a copy of
this of course but if you don't want to
buy it and you feel like having a bit of
a look through it the stanford libraries
actually has a license to the o'reilly
Safari Books collection so you can start
off at library and for ddu and read it
for free there's one catch to this which
is the library only has 16 simultaneous
licenses to Safari books
so if you'd also like your classmates to
be able to read it for free it really
helps if you remember to log out of
Safari Books Online when you're done
looking at it um yeah so this is sort of
it I mean in some sense I hope you will
feel if you look at this book boy I
already know most of that stuff already
it's not a super advanced book but it's
a good well-written tutorial of how to
do things with Pi torch and NLP if you
don't feel like you know most of the
stuff in this book you can let me know
but I will be a little sad ok yeah so
let's so starting into today so we spent
a lot of time on recurrent neural
networks and they're great for many
things but there's sort of some things
that they're not so good at so you know
we kind of might like to know about a
phrase like my birth or a bigger phrase
like of my birth and there's sort of no
independent representation of those
spans and a recurrent neural network we
kind of get sort of prefixes of a whole
sentence and while we did bi-directional
recurrent your networks and you could
say well wait a minute you could use it
in both directions and to some extent
that's true you could get stuff from
this direction and stuff from this
direction but we still kind of have sort
of whole sequences that go to one end of
the sentence or another we don't just
have pieces of sentences and
often we'd like to sort of work out
meanings of pieces of sentences and so
we sort of have two problems here we
only have sort of initial and final sub
sequences and also if you look at these
representations like if you say take
this last state as the representation of
the meaning of this text what you find
out is it's very dominated by the
meaning of the most recent words and
what they're trying to predict as to
what comes after them and that's part of
the reason why I mentioned last time in
the question-answering lecture the idea
that while you can do better by having a
sentinel and training something that has
attention over the whole lsdm structure
okay but today we're going to look at a
different alternative which is
convolutional neural nets which are
often abbreviated as either cnn's or
comp nets and the idea of these is well
look maybe we could just take every
subsequence of a certain length and
calculate a representation for it so
that you know if we have some piece of
text like Tintin of do reach to keep
government open and we could sort of
just say well let's just take all three
words sequences tentative deal reached
deal reach to reach to keep etc and
we're going to calculate some kind of
representation for each of those
sequences so this isn't us isn't a
strongly linguistic idea right we're not
worrying about is whether it's a
coherent phrase that's grammatical
linguistically valid cognitively
plausible we just take every subsequence
of a certain length and then once we've
calculated representations of those
we're going to look at how to group them
okay so let's get into more detail as to
what cnn's are and how they work yeah so
there's this general idea of a
convolution which you may or may not
have seen in some math or Electrical
Engineering class and then there's the
particular version of con
Lucian's that are discreet convolutions
which you can means that you can use the
friendly summation symbol rather than an
integral and that's a that's a discrete
convolution I find that that notation is
completely unhelpful so I won't even try
and explain it but I've got lots of
examples and convolutions are really
easy for neural nets in terms of what
they do for examples right - the classic
case of where convolutional neural
networks are used is in vision
application so if you do CS 231 in next
quarter essentially you know the first
four weeks is just all doing
convolutional neural networks in all
their variants and glory and the sort of
a central idea of convolutions for
vision is that you want to recognize
things no matter where they appear in an
image so you have a sort of property of
translation and variance and the idea of
a convolution as a way of finding
something in different places in the
image regardless of where it appears so
this is the vision example which I stole
from androids UFL DL website and so what
a convolution is is it's here a patch
but you can think of it as just as as a
vector and the patch has weights which
are these little numbers in red and what
you're going to do is slide that patch
over the image as this in as this
animation does and so in each position
you're going to multiply each of the red
numbers by the black number of that
position and then you're just going to
sum them up so that's what a discrete
convolution does which is what that
notation at the top saying right you're
multiplying things together and then
you're summing them up and so you're
doing this and then you're filling in
the pink with the products the sum
product so it's sort of like you're
taking these sort of patch dot products
and putting them into the pink matrix
and that's then york involved feature so
that's a 2d convolution which for the
rest of today we're not going to look at
anymore so this is all you're learning
about vision and so we're now going to
go back and look at 1d convolutions
which is what people use when they using
convolution on your networks for text so
the starting point of a convolutional
neural network for text is we have an
input so here's my sentence and for each
word in the sentence
I've here got a dense word vector I made
it a four do you want to keep it small
in my example but usually as you know
it's more so our starting point is we
have some input
you know what the input could just be a
one hot encoding that's not forbidden
here but normally we'll have these kind
of dense word vectors and so then it's
sort of the same as the 3d as the 2d one
apart from we've only got one dimension
so we have a filter so here is our
filter and so our filter is going to do
three steps in time three words and it's
going to work across the dimensions so
these different dimensions in the
convolutional neural network often get
referred to as channels so we're kind of
working across the input channels and so
we have a patch like this and we're
going to take this patch and put it on
top of the first three words I don't
have this good an animation as the
previous slide sorry
and we're going to work out the dot
product between those and I did that at
home by putting this into Excel and the
answer of that is that the product is
minus 1.0 and then at that point we
slide our we slide this matrix which
gets referred to as a kernel or a filter
which is the patch that we're using to
our convolution on your network we slide
it down one and do the dot product of
those terms again and that comes out as
minus 1/2 and we keep on sliding that
down and we get what get what's shown on
the right as our output so at this point
we've just reduced the sentence to a
single vector
and that seems like we might want to do
more than that but the other thing that
you all have noticed is that our
sentences sort of shrunk because before
you know we had a seven word sentence
but because I just saw a slid this three
word kernel down here I ended up with
only five positions to put it in so it's
become a five word thing so the first of
all address that problem commonly when
people do convolutional neural networks
they add padding so what I can do is I
can add zero padding at both ends and
then sort of do the same trick and say
run a convolution on that and now I'll
be able to put my size three filter in
seven different places as I slide it
down and so I'm getting out a vector
that's the same length of my input that
you know there are different ways so
this is the most common way of doing
things and it's kind of seems logical
because it maintains size I mean you
know there's always more than one way to
do it if you really wanted to you hopes
I mean what do you mean whoops
huh
I had a slight mistake on my slide
because this turns out which I was about
to get to in a minute that I'll just
explain this bit here anyway you know if
you wanted to you could have two steps
of padding on it both ends here so that
your first convolution would be looking
at zero zero tentative and then the
convolution would actually grow the size
of your input No yeah but yes so I mean
so when we done so far
we'd started with these word vectors
which in convolutional neural networks
terms were of length four so our kind of
input had four channels but when we were
back
here we were just producing from this
Colonel one column of output so our
output has only a single channel so
we've sort of shrunk things in the
columns direction from four to one and
that might seem bad and for many
purposes it is bad and so a lot of the
time what you want to do is to say well
rather than have only one filter instead
of that why don't I have several filters
so here I've got three different filters
and each of these filters is just sort
of a same size three three the size the
kernel size times the input number of
channels for matrix so I have three
different filters and I'm going to run
each one down the text and get a column
here so now I'm ending up with three
columns of output and so I have a sort
of a three channel output and the way to
intuitive lis think of this is for these
filters well you know for what we do in
neural networks we're going to learn
them by back propagation like everything
else but our hope is that these filters
could somehow specialize in different
things so maybe this filter could
specialize on is this language polite
and it'll produce a high value whenever
it sees polite words and maybe this
filter could specialize I don't know
eating and it'll have a high value
whenever it sees words about food and
you know this filter will do a third
thing and so we can that's the sense in
which people sometimes talk about the
what you're getting is output of
different features because your hope is
that you'll kind of gain different
latent features coming out of the text
okay so that gives us a representation
and that's sort of a useful sort of
having
learn features in our text that quite
often though what we'll want to do is
just summarize the text with respect to
those features so you might just have
the question of well in this piece of
text is it polite and does it talk about
food so another operation that will
quite often do is want to summarize the
output of convolutional Network and the
simplest way to do that is for 1d
convolutions it's called max pooling
over time so if we max pull over time
for each of the channels or otherwise
known as features we're just simply
going to look down and see what is its
maximum value 0.3 1.6 1.4 and so you
know if I use my story about the first
two filters it's sort of saying well
it's not very polite text but it's
really about food right there we're sort
of summarizing what we've detected there
um so the concept of max pooling in some
sense captures does is this thing being
activated anywhere right so if we have
things like politeness and about food
that the output of max pooling will have
a high value if somewhere in the
sentence there was a clear marker of
politeness or something clearly about
food and that's often a useful notion
because often what you want to know is
you know is there some discussion of
food in this sentence or is there not
there's another thing there are other
things that you could do instead of max
pooling
you can instead do average pooling so
here you just take these numbers and
find the average of them that then has
the different semantics which is sort of
what's the average amount of politeness
of this text or on average how much you
know how the scent of the sentences
about food or something like that for
some purposes this is better because you
know it takes in all of the important
builds through an average and
a lot of the time people have found that
actually max pulling is better because
you know a lot of signals and natural
language sparse you know no matter how
polite you're trying to be you're not
going to be being polite in every word
you're going to say nouns and articles
like that and are and prepositions and
conjunctions none of which are
inherently polite right so that if
there's some politeness showing up
prominently then the sentence becomes
polite and max pooling is actually
better for capturing that of course the
one other kind of thing that you can do
is min pooling and find the least active
thing doesn't get used much but you
could do that as well okay so so if
you're in PI torch this is all pretty
easy stuff to do so there's a handy
dandy cond one D there's also Kampf to D
as you might guess revision but there's
a con one D where you're specifying how
many input channels there are that was
our word embedding sighs how many output
channels there are we had three what the
size of the convolutional kernel is so
the ones that we were showing were also
three and then there are various other
parameters you can have I can say that
you want a padding of one and things
like that and then once you've got one
of those you can just sort of run your
convolutional filter on the input to get
a new hidden state and then if you want
to max pull you can just mix through the
output of that and then you've got a max
pulled output okay so that gives us the
basics of building a kind of a
convolutional neural network for NLP
that sort of makes sense up until there
yeah okay so
next bit is to sort of show you three or
four other things that you can do
I started off typing these slides other
less useful notions because I kind of
thought at least don't really come up
much an NLP but you know actually it
turned out when I got on to that that
second paper when I say the complex
convolutional neural network actually in
that paper they try out just about all
of these things that I say no one uses
so it's sort of good to know what they
are for looking at various papers so you
know when we did things so far then we
were calculating these convolutions that
we were sort of trying them out at every
position so he had one four zero
tentative deal then four tentative deal
reach then deal reach to and so we were
just walking down one step at a time
which is referred to as a Striders of
one and that's by far the most common
thing to do but you could observe look
wait a minute since the first
convolution concerns zero tentative deal
I've got all those three words in there
even if I skip down to and next did deal
reached two and then I did to keep
government I'd still have in one or
other of the convolutions every word of
the sentence so I can do half as much
computation and I've still got
everything in there in some sense and so
that's referred to as using the stride
of two and so then I get something with
half as many rows out so it's one way to
sort of compactify your representation
and produce something shorter from a
longer sentence and we'll see that use
of it coming up later there's other ways
to compactify what cut representation
that comes out of your sentence and so
there's a different notion of pooling
which is local pooling now in if if
you've seen any of the vision world when
people talk about max pulley and vision
they normally mean local pooling as
opposed to the max pooling through time
that I showed you first so
here we are sort of back to where we
started and we've done our size three
stride one convolution which is
producing output as before but now what
I'm going to do is local pool with a
stride of two which means I'm going to
take each two rows and I'm going to pull
them together into one row and I could
do that again by the maxing or averaging
or whatever appeals to me so I take the
first two rows I max pull when I get
this I take the next to roll rows I'm ex
pull them I get this next to next two
and I've sort of patted on the bottom so
I have two rows at the bottom and so
that's then give me a local max pooling
of a stride of two and that sort of had
exactly the same effect in the sense but
with a different result as using a
stride of two in my convolution because
I've again reduced it to something of
four rows that used to be eight rows
yeah okay so that's that one what else
can you do there are more things you can
do to make it complex another thing that
people have sometimes done is kmx
pooling and so this is a more complex
thing and it's sort of saying well
rather than just keeping the max over
time if a feature is being kind of
activated two or three times in the
sentence maybe it'd be good to record
all the times that is activated in the
sentence while throwing away the rest so
in K max pooling and I'm doing two max
here you look down this column and you
find the two highest values for that
column but then you put the two highest
values not in the order of highest to
lowest but in the order in which they
are in these columns so it's minus 0.2
0.3 for this one and it's one point six
zero point six to this one because it
reflects the orders of the caller
up above okay almost done one more
concept this is another way of
compressing data which is a dilated
convolution so if you have a dilated
convolution so dilated convolution doing
it over here doesn't really make sense
but where you can use a dilated
convolution is if I take this and put it
through another convolutional layer we
can kind of have deep convolutional
networks that have multiple
convolutional layers so the idea of a
dilated calm convolution is you're going
to skip some of the rows so if you use a
dilation of two starting at the top
you're going to take the first third and
the fifth row and multiply them by my
fitness re I have different filters
multiplied them by my filters and then
get the values that appear here and then
if Striders one you'd then use that
you'd go on and sort of do the next
spread out rows and so this allows you
to have convolutions that see a bigger
spread of the sentence without having
many parameters so you don't have to do
things this way you could have said oh
look I could just instead have
convolutions with the kernel size of
five and then they'd say 555 words in a
row but then I'd be having sort of
bigger matrices to specify my feature
whereas this way I can keep the matrices
small but still see a bigger range of
the sentence in one operation yeah and
that concept of how much of a sentence
you see is kind of an important notion
in convolutional neural networks because
you know if you start at the beginning
of a sentence and you're just running
three by three convolutions you're sort
of seeing these three word patches of
the sentence
and it turns out a natural language
that's already actually quite a useful
representation because sort of having
those kind of engrams as features is
just good for many purposes including
text classification but if you want to
sort of understand more of the semantics
of a center and somehow you want to see
more of it at once and you've sort of
got several tools you can use to see
more of at once you can use bigger
filters you could use a kernel size five
seven nine or something convolution you
could do something like dilated
convolution so you can see spread out
pictures and the third thing that you
can do is you could have depth of a
convolutional neural network because as
you have greater depth of a
convolutional neural network you see
more so this first layer the rows now
have sort of info about three words in
them and if you sort of just stuck a
second layer of convolutional neural
network with the same general nature on
top of it and you sort of take the first
three rows and convolve it again then
and then the next ones that those then
know about five words of your original
input sentence so as you kind of have a
deeper continent stack you start to know
about bigger and bigger patches of the
sentence okay all good
any questions okay so the next piece is
essentially shows you this stuff again
in the context of a particular paper so
this was a paper by Eun Kim who was a
harvard student maybe still as a Harvard
student in 2014 so this was sort of a
fairly early paper and he wanted to show
that you could use convolutional neural
networks to do a good job for doing text
classification when what you want to
classify is a single sentence so the
kind of thing you might want to do is
look at the kind of snippets of movie
reviews that you see on the Rotten
Tomatoes side and say is this a positive
or is this
and negative sentence description and
the model he built is actually kind of
similar to the convolutional neural
networks that Cola bear and Western
introduced in their 2011 paper that we
mentioned before when we're talking
about window based classifiers so in
their paper they actually used both
window based classifiers and the
convolutional classifier okay so yeah I
sort of already said this so their tasks
are sentence classification could be
sentiment it could be other things like
is this sentence subjective or objective
so objective is what the main news
articles are meant to be and subjective
is what the opinion pieces are meant to
be and then other things like question
classification is this a question asking
about a person location number or
whatever okay so here is what he did and
it's sort of but these slides sort of
used the notation of his paper which is
sort of a little bit different the way
the math gets written down to what I
just showed you but it's really doing
exactly the same thing so we start with
word vectors of length K the sentence is
made by just concatenating all those
word vectors together and then when we
so we have a range of words it's a
subpart of that sentence vector and so
the convolutional filter is just being
represented as a vector because here
he's flattened everything out into one
long vector for the entire sentence
whereas I had sort of stacked into a
matrix and so a size three convolution
is just a real vector of length H K the
size of the convolutional filter times
the dimensionality of the words and so
what he's going to do to build his text
classifier is use convolutions made out
of different sizes so you can have size
two convolutions size three convolutions
are shown here and bigger convolutions
and so so to compute a feature on one
channel for our CNN we're then doing a
dot product between the weight vector of
the feature times the subsequence of the
sentence and he sort of also put in a
bias which I sort of embittered and then
putting it through a non-linearity which
I wasn't doing either but it's sort of
we've seen a ton of and so what we
wanting to do is that's our feature and
we want to do it through all this for a
feature of its kernel size three we're
going to go all the way through the
sentence the other thing he did there
was slightly funnel funny is his windows
were sort of lopsided in the notation
right there's a word and the H minus one
words to the right of it so he has
padding here just on the right end
whereas most people do their convolution
symmetrically in both directions around
things okay and so we're going to do
that for a bunch of features or channels
ci and therefore computer convolved
representations just as we've talked
about okay then he does just what you
talked about there's max over time
pooling in the pooling layer to capture
the most relevant things and it's giving
us a single number for each channel and
we have features that look at different
that have different kernel sizes here's
one other idea he used which is possibly
a neat idea he knows one of the things
that you could even think about in
various ways for say a question
answering system among other things is
so he used pre-trained word vectors but
what he did was he actually kind of
doubled the
word vectors so for each word he had two
copies of the word vector and so you
have sort of two channel sets and one
set he froze and the other one he
fine-tuned as he trained so so if he
tried to get the best of both worlds of
sort of fine tuning and not fine tuning
and all that went into the max pooling
operation okay so after the max pooling
we get out one number for each channel
and so he has something of three sized
convolutions three four five a hundred
features for each size so we're getting
out of vector of size 300 at that point
and at that point you're taking that
final vector and just sticking it
through a soft Max and that's then
giving your classification into classes
so all of that can be summarized in this
picture if it's big enough to sort of
read so here's our sentence I like this
movie very much which has you know our
word embedding dimension is five and so
then doing it in this example we're
having two channels for each kernel size
and we consider kernels of size two
three and four and so and then we're
getting two different ones so we're
getting six this is showing six of our
filters so we apply those and we are
when we apply those filters without any
padding we're then getting out these
outputs of the filters which are of
sizes 4 5 and 6 respectively and so then
once we've got these for each of these
sets of numbers we're doing one max
pooling so we're just taking the max of
each of these output features which
gives us these six numbers we can
concatenate them all together into one
vector which
we feed into a softmax over two classes
as the weather sentiment is positive or
negative so that's basically the model
so something so this is sort of really
actually a very simple very
computationally efficient model as to
how to build a text classifier yeah just
a couple more things to get through so
in one of the assignments we talked
about dropout and you used it so you
know hopefully all masters have dropout
at this point so he was using dropout
and this being 2014 and the dropout
paper only coming out in 2014 I guess
they'd been an earlier version that came
out a couple of years earlier this was
sort of still fairly early to be taking
advantage of dropout so that while
training you've got this sort of dropout
vector where you sample your Bernoulli
random variables and you're sort of them
sort of deciding to drop out some of the
features each time you're doing things
at testing time you don't do the dropout
but because before you were sort of
dropping out a lot of stuff you're
scaling your weight matrix by the same
probability that you use for dropping
out so that you get sort of vectors of
the same scale as before so as we sort
of discussed in the assignment drop out
is a really effective form of
regularization widely used in your
networks he didn't only do that he
actually did a kind of another sort of
funky form of regularization so that's
for the softmax weight vector he
constrained the old to norms
so the squared norms of the weight
vectors and the softmax matrix to a
fixed number s which was sort of said of
the hyper parameter has actually set the
value three and if your weights were
getting too large
there are being
scaled so they didn't blow up and this
isn't a very common thing to do I'm not
sure it's very necessary but I guess it
gives you some I mean I guess by showing
you a few of the details of this one of
my hopes is sort of gives you some ideas
about how there are lots of things you
can play around with and muck with if
you want to try different things for
your final projects okay so here are
some of his final hyper parameters so
he's using really non linearities window
sizes of three four and five for the
convolutions hundred features or
channels for each size drop out of a
half as usual you get several percentage
improvements and drop out which is quite
common actually the sort of l2
constraint s equals three mini batch of
fifty three hundred dimensional word
vectors trained to maximize their set
performance okay and here is the big
table now as too lazy to redo of
performance on these different text
classification datasets there are lots
of different ones so these two are both
Stanford's intimate treebank
this is the subjective objective
language this is the question
classification of is it asking for
person name a location a company or
whatever this is talking about sort of a
perspective which is another
classification thing Consumer Reports is
another sentiment one so lots of data
sets and then here are lots of models so
the model some of the models down here
or here a traditional feature based
classifiers so in particular silhouette
and me back in 2012 had sort of pointed
out that by taking certain steps within
gramm features and other forms of
normalization that you could actually
get quite good results with just a
traditional feature based classifier so
many people use
as a baseline for showing that you can
do better things the ones up here where
tree-structured neural networks that my
group was very fond of in the early 2010
and then up the very top his CNN morals
and as you can see it's sort of a mix
sometimes the CNN model wins like in
this column in this column sometimes it
doesn't win like in these columns but in
general what you can see from this is
that you know this is an extremely
simple convolutional neural network
model and it actually does kind of well
on this system you can quibble with this
results table and again in terms of like
writing your proposed project proposal
one thing that you should do is kind of
think about what you're reading because
you know a lot of papers aren't perfect
and their reasons to quibble with what
they claim and sometimes if you think
about what they're claiming and whether
it's reasonable there are reasons why
it's not or there are ideas of how you
could do things differently or show
something different I mean the main
reason why you could quibble with Yuna
Kim's results table is well he already
said as I had a couple of slides back
that the statement that drop out gives
you two to four percent accuracy
improvement in his neural nets but most
of these systems because they're older
and were done before drop out was
invented didn't make use of drop out but
you know any of these sort of neural net
systems up here could have used drop out
and presumably it would have given them
a couple of percent gain as well so
arguably this is sort of a biased unfair
comparison and the right thing would
have been to be comparing all the
systems using dropout but you know
despite that you know this was still a
pretty a lot of people notice this paper
because it showed that using this sort
of very
simple very fast convolutional
architecture could give you strong
results for text classification that's
that yeah so in summary you know
something that you should be thinking
about for projects and otherwise we're
effectively building up a bigger toolkit
of different tools you could be using
for projects or future work or whatever
it is so starting off with we had word
vectors and then we could build bag of
vector models by just taking the word
vectors and averaging them and you know
that's actually a surprisingly good
baseline to start with we suggest to you
in many cases for things like projects
you should use that see how well it does
make sure you're working better I mean
particularly you can do even better with
that if you sort of add some extra value
layers on top which is an idea that's
being explored in deep averaging
networks then we looked at window models
which were very simple you're just
taking these sort of five word windows
and computing a feed for network on them
and they work very well for word
classification problems that only need
local context things like part of speech
tagging right any are but then we've
gone ahead and looked at some other
models and so CNN's are very good for
text classification and they're very
good because they parallel lies really
well on GPUs which is something I'll
come back to again later so they they're
just sound for general sort of
representing sentence meaning they're
actually a efficient versatile good
method which has being used quite a bit
and then they sort of contrast with
recurrent neural networks recurrent
neural networks have some advantages
there so more cognitively plausible
because just sort of reading through the
text and getting its meaning recurrent
neural networks are good for things like
sequence tagging and classification
building language models to predict
what's coming next they can do really
well when combined with the tension but
they also have some disadvantages
they're way slower than convolutional
neural networks
and if what you want to do is get out
some kind of overall meaning
representation of a sentence you know
what does this mean are these two
phrases paraphrases with each other
there are now many results that show
that people don't get better results
with recurrent neural networks they can
get better results using techniques like
convolutional neural networks ok so the
next step then is to sort of head
towards our calm our complex
convolutional architecture example so
before getting to that I just want to
sort of introduce a few concepts that we
haven't seen all of which start to turn
up when we do this so we spent a lot of
time in the sequent models part talking
about gated models or the gated
recurrent units and the LS TM units but
the idea of a gate is general that we
can sort of have this idea that we can
calculate something put it through a
sigmoid non-linearity and get a value
between 0 and 1 or vector of values
between 0 and 1 and then do a HUD amount
product with a vector and sort of gate
it between its value and 0 so that
suggests the idea that you could also
apply gates vertically when you're
building multi-layer networks and after
this success of L STM's had been proven
that was I'm an idea that really took
off was people start exploring how can
we have use these ideas of skip
connections and gating in a in a
vertical direction and here are two
versions of it this one is a very simple
one but a very successful one that's
basically just about a skip connection
so and this is referred to as a residual
block and which is used in residual
networks otherwise known as resonance so
in a residual block for each block you
allow a value just to skip ahead
to the next layer or you can stick it
through a conf block and the typical
cond block is you go through a
convolutional layer you then go through
a railing on linearity another
convolutional layer and then when you
come out you just sum these two values
so there's the same idea that sort of
summing values as magical in the same
way as an LS TM and then you put the
output of that through another relu and
this thing here is called a residual
block and then commonly your stack
residual blocks on top of each other um
there's one little trick here which is
you need to use padding right because at
the end of the day since you want to sum
these two pathways
you want them to be the same size and if
you sort of have them shrinking in the
comp blocks you won't be able to sum
them so you want to sort of have a
padding at each stage so they stay the
same size here and so that you can add
them together here's a different version
of a block which is sort of more LST M
ish and indeed this block was developed
by jurgen schmidhuber and students who's
the same guy who was behind LST M's and
you can see the same thinking it's
called a highway block so in a way it's
sort of similar you've got you're kind
of thinking of moving an identity X that
skips a nonlinear block or you can have
it go through exactly the same staff
cond Relic on the difference is that
unlike this one this time there's
explicit gate so there's at this t gate
in the see gate and so you're
multiplying both of the paths through
here and the path through here by a gate
just kind of like the sort of forget
input gates and we saw before and then
summing them together so that sort of
feels more powerful but it's not
actually clear that it is more powerful
I mean this one actually has a very
simple sum
antics because you can think of the
semantics of this one is the default is
just you walk this way and you just sort
of carry forward your value and do
nothing so what this blocks job to is to
do is to learn a delta that it's meant
to learn what kind of deviation you have
from doing nothing so that's a nice
simple semantics which seems to work
well in neural networks to learn things
this sort of has a more complicated
apparent semantics because you're taking
you know some parts of the identity
multiplying by this sort of gaze in a
hard product and some parts of this
conned balk multiplied by this other
gate T and ahead of odd product so that
sort of feels more powerful as if that
gives me a lot more control because I
take pieces of the different ones and so
on if you think about it for a bit
longer
I mean mathematically it's actually not
any more powerful that you can represent
anything you can do with this one with
that one and the way to think about that
is well you know here you're kind of
keeping only part of the identity but
what you could do is keep the whole of
the identity and see it as your job to
subtract off the bits that this one
isn't keeping over here in the conv lock
which you can do theoretically and so
you could sort of anything you can
compute with this as a function you can
actually compute with a ResNet block and
so then as quite often in your network
land the question isn't sort of some
kind of proof of compute can be computed
or not it sort of comes down to learning
and regularization questions as to
whether one or the other of these
actually proves better as something to
use in a learning architecture ok sick
concept betch normalization so when
people are building deep convolutional
neural networks in the 2015 pluses they
almost always use batch normalization
layers because this makes your life a
lot better and if they're not using
batch normalization layers they're
normally using one of the other variant
ideas that people are suggested such as
layer normalization which is sort of
meant to do about the same thing
so what batch normalization does I mean
I think many of you will have seen
somewhere in steps or otherwise the idea
of doing a Z transform which means you
take your data you work out its mean and
you work out its standard deviation and
then you rescale by subtraction and
multiplication so that you have a set of
data which has an mean of 0 and a
standard deviation of 1 most people have
seen that right yeah so batch
normalization is effectively doing
exactly that but in a weird way
so what you're doing is that you're
taking each mini batch so whatever just
random 32 examples you've stuck in a
mini batch you're running them through a
layer of your neural network like a cond
walk that we saw before and you take the
output of that mini batch and then you
do a Z transform on it and then it goes
forward until the next con walk or
whatever and the next time you have a
different many batch you just Z
transform it so it seems a little bit
weird you're just doing it on the output
of these mini batches but that's proven
to be a very effective thing to do so
that it sort of means that what comes
out of a cond block sort of always has
the same kind of scale so it doesn't
sort of fluctuate a lot and mess things
up and it tends to make the models just
much more reliably trainable because you
know you just have to be much less fussy
about a lot of
because you know a lot of the things
we've talked about about initializing
your parameters and setting your
learning rates are sort of about well
you have to keep the scale of things
about right so they don't get too big or
too small and things like that whereas
if you're doing this batch normalization
you're sort of forcing scale to being
the same size each time and so therefore
you kind of don't have to do the other
stuff as well and it still tends to work
pretty well so that's a good technique
to know about okay one last thing to
learn about there's a concept of size
one convolutions and actually I guess I
really sort of renamed this I named this
wrong because I wrote down one by one
convolutions because that's the term you
normally see but that's the vision world
where you have two deconvolution x'
so I guess I should have just called
this one convolutions so you can have
convolutions with the kernel size of one
and when you first see that it seems
like that makes no sense whatsoever
because the whole idea of convolution
was I was taking this patch and
calculating something from it if I'm not
looking at any other words surely I'm
calculating nothing but what actually
happens in the size one convolution is
if you have a number of channels that
sort of in a previous layer if you had
calculated whatever it was 32 channels
or something like that but the one by
one convolution is doing is acting as a
teeny little embedded fully connected
network over those channels and so
you're sort of doing position-specific
fully connected network in for each row
of your data and so you can do that for
various reasons you can do it because
you want to map down from having a lot
of channels to having fewer channels or
you can do it just because you think and
another non-linearity will help and this
is a really cheap way to do it because
the crucial thing to notice is that if
you sort of put fully connected layers
over everything they involve a lot of
parameters whereas putting in these size
one convolutions involve very few
parameters because you're just doing it
them at the level of a single word okay
through random things and I'll go on to
my complex model this is just a sort of
almost a bias aside but it just shows
something different that you could do
and it's something that you could play
with I mean when we talked about machine
translation we talked about the seek to
seek architecture that was introduced in
2014 and has been very successful for
machine translation but actually the
year before that came out there was a
paper doing neural machine translation
by now couch burner and Phil one--some
in the UK and this is sort of was
actually essentially the first Newell
machine translation paper of the modern
era
if you dig back far enough they're
actually a couple of people that tried
to use neural networks for machine
translation in the 80s and 90s but this
was sort of the first one that restarted
it and they didn't actually use a seek
to seek architecture so what they used
was for the encoder they used the
convolutional neural networks and so
that they had a stack of convolutional
neural networks that progressively
shrunk down the input and then finally
pulled it to get a sentence
representation and then they used a
sequence model as their decoder so
that's sort of something that you could
try and some other applications that for
encoders it's really easy to use
convolutional neural networks there has
been work on using convolutional neural
networks as decoders as well so that's a
little bit harder to get your brain
around and isn't use nearly as much then
the second thing I want to mention
because we'll turn to it and just
minute is so so far we've done
convolutional models over words so that
our our kernels are effectively picking
up these word Engram units of two word
or three word sub sequences an idea that
then developed fairly soon was well
maybe it had also been useful to use
convolutions over characters so you can
run a convolutional neural network over
the characters of the word to try and
generate a word embedding and this idea
has been explored quite a lot it's part
of what you guys are going to do for
assignment 5 is build a character level
ComNet for your improved machine
translation system I'm not going to say
sort of a huge amount about the
foundations of this today because
Thursday's lecture is then talking about
sub word models and we'll go through all
the details of different sub word models
but I wanted to show you a calm a
complex convolutional neural network
which is also used for text
classification so essentially the same
tasks as Yoon's model and this model
actually is built on characters it's not
built on words so we are at the
foundation of it having a word like
model so this is a paper from 2017 by
the four authors shown here people work
in facebook AI research in France and so
they kind of had an interesting
hypothesis for this paper which was
essentially to say that you know by 2017
people who are using deep learning for
vision were building really really deep
networks and finally finding that they
work much much better for vision tasks
so essentially to some extent the
breakthrough was these guys that once
these ideas are emerged it then proved
that it wasn't just that you could build
a six layer or and
laya convolutional neural network for
vision tasks you could start building
really really deep networks for vision
tasks which had tens or even hundreds of
layers and that those models when
trained on a lot of data proved to work
even better so if that's what's in your
head and you then looked look at what
was and indeed is happening in natural
language processing the observation is
you know these NLP people are kind of
pathetic they claim they're doing deep
learning but they're still working with
three layer LS TMS surely we can make
some progress by building really deep
networks that kind of look like vision
networks and using them for natural
language processing goals and so that is
precisely what they said about doing so
that they designed and built really deep
Network which sort of looks like a
vision stack as a convolutional neural
network that is built over characters so
I've got the picture of it here but
sufficiently deep that it's fitting it
on the slide and making it readable it's
a little bit of a challenge but we can
try and look at this so at the bottom we
have the text which is a sequence of
characters and so for the text so when
people do vision object recognition on
pictures normally all the pictures are
made the same size right you make every
picture 300 pixels by 300 pixels or
something like that so they do exactly
the same for NLP they have a size for
their document which is a thousand and
24 characters if it's longer than that
they truncate it keep the first part if
it's shorter than that they Pat it until
it's of size 1024 and then they're going
to stick it into their stack so the
first part is that for each character
they're going to learn a character
and their character embeddings are of
dimensionality 16 so that the piece of
text is now 16 by a thousand and 24 so
they're going to stick that through a
convolutional layer where you've got
kernel size of three and sixty-four
output channels so you now have
something that's 64 times 1,024 in size
you now stick this through a
convolutional block I'll explain the
details of that convolutional block on
the next slide but you should be
thinking of that ResNet picture I showed
earlier where you can either be going
through some convolutions or taking this
optional shortcut another resinate
another residual block where you can be
going through convolutions or an
optional short card there then doing
local pooling in the same way people
typically do envision so commonly what
people do in vision systems is you're
sort of shrinking the size of the images
by doing pooling that halves the
dimensions in each direction but at the
same time you do that in your neural
network you expand the number of
channels and so you hit make it deeper
in terms of the number of channels at
the same times you make it smaller in
the X Y size of the image so they do
exactly the same apart from these
one-dimensional convolutions so before
we had 64 channels in our 1,024
character embedding document so now we
pull it so we can have 512 positions
which are sort of like pairs of
characters but we now have a hundred
twenty-eight channels and then they kind
of repeat that over and over again right
so there are two more convolutional
blocks which I'll explain more but
they're sort of residual blocks they
pull it again and they do exactly the
same thing so now there are 256
positions which are like four character
blocks and they have 256 channels I
can't point high enough but they repeat
that again
and they pull again so now they've got
128 positions which are about eight
characters each and they have 512
channels representing that they pull
again they have convolutional blocks
again then lo and behold because I said
even the weird idea is going to turn up
right up there they're doing k-max
pulling and they're keeping the eight
strongest values in each channel and so
at that point they've got something of
size 512 by 8 so you know so like 8 of
the 8 character sequences have been
deemed important for the classification
and there have kept but this sort of
channel on their 512 of them you know
then putting that through three fully
connected layers so typically vision
systems at the top have a couple of
fully connected layers at the end and
the very last one of those is
effectively sort of feeding into your
softmax
so it's size and 2048 times the number
of classes which might just be positive
negative to class or might be topical
classes so yeah so it's essentially like
a vision stack but they're going to use
it for language okay so the bit that I
haven't quite explained was these
convolutional blocks but it sort of
looked like the picture that we had
before or apartment slightly more
complicated so you're doing a
convolutional block of size 3
convolution some number of channels
depending on where you are in the
sequence you're then putting it through
a batch norm as we've just talked about
putting it through a rail you
non-linearity repeating of those three
things again or remember there was the
sort of skip connection that went right
around the outside of this block and so
this is sort of residual style block so
that's the kind of complex architecture
you can put together and try and your
final projects if you dare in PI torch
yeah so
for experiments so so one of the things
that they were interested in and wanted
to make a point of is while some of
these the traditional sentence and text
classification data sets have been used
in other papers like yoon kim's paper
are effectively quite small so something
like that Rotten Tomatoes data set is
actually only 10,000 examples 5,000
positive 5,000 negative and they sort of
have the idea that just like image net
was needed for deep learning models to
really show their Worth and vision that
probably to show the value of a huge
model like that and you need to have
really big data set so they get some
much bigger text classification data set
so here's an amazon review positive
negative data set with which they have
so 3.6 million documents Yelp reviews
650,000 documents so much bigger data
sets and here are the their experiments
okay so the numbers at the top for the
different data sets of the best previous
result printed in the literature and
then if you read the footnotes there are
a few things that they want to sort of
star so the ones that have a star next
to them used an external force Oris
which they don't use and the yang method
used some special techniques as well
that I cut off on the other thing to
mention is these numbers their error
rate so low is good and so the lower you
get them the better and so then these
are all of their results and so what can
you get out of these results well the
first thing that you can notice is
basically with these results
the deeper networks are working better
right so the one that I showed you
well no I think the one that I have the
picture of isn't the full thing but they
have ones with depth 917 and 29 in turn
the number of convolutional layers and
the deepest one is always the one that's
working best so that's a proof of deep
networks that didn't keep on working so
an interesting footnote here is I guess
they thought oh this is cool why don't
we try an even deeper one that has 47
layers and see how well that works and I
mean the results were sort of
interesting for that so for the 47 layer
worm it worked a fraction worse than
this one so in one sense you they showed
the result of sort of residual layers
work really well so they did an
experiment of let's try it train a forty
seven layer Network without using
residual connections and well it was a
lot worse and the numbers went down
about two percent and they trained one
with residual connections and the fact
of the matter is the numbers were just a
teeny-weeny bit worse there are sort of
0.1 of a percent worse so you know it's
sort of work just about as well but
nevertheless that's kind of different to
the situation envisioned because for the
sort of residual networks of people are
using envision this is sort of like the
very minimum depth that people use so if
you're using residual networks and
vision typically you might use ResNet 34
if you're really short on memory and
want to have a small model but you just
know you'd get better results if you use
the ResNet 50 and in fact if you used
and resonant 101 and work even better
again and so that somehow you know
whether it's got to do with a different
nature of language or the amount of data
or something you haven't yet gone to the
same depth that you can envision but
other results so the other thing they're
comparing here is that they're comparing
three different ways of sort of
shrinking things down so you could be
using the stride in the convolution you
can be using
local max pulling and you could be using
K Mex pulling and there general there
are slightly different numbers as you
can see each one wins and one a at least
one of these data sets are actually at
least two of these data sets but not
only does max pulling win four for the
data sets if you sort of look at the
numbers
max pulling always does pretty well
because max pooling does pretty well
here whereas the convolutional stride
works badly and over here next pooling
works pretty well and the kmx pooling
works kind of badly so their
recommendation at the end of the day is
you should always use just max pooling
of a simple kind that that seems to be
fine
and nothing else is actually worth the
trouble of thinking about doing okay
most of any other conclusions I wanted
to say okay I think that was most of it
I guess their overall message is you can
build super good text classification
systems using confidence and you should
take away that message okay so they're
just a couple of minutes left there is
sort of one other thing I've wanted to
mention but I think I'll just sort of
mention it very quickly and you can look
in more detail if you want to so we sort
of have this situation that the
recurrent your networks are a very
standard building block for NLP but they
have this big problem that they just
don't paralyze well and the way we get
fast computation and deep learning is we
find things that parallel eyes well so
that we can stick them on GPUs GPUs only
a fast if they can be simultaneously
doing the same computation many times
which is sort of trivial for
convolutional neural network because
precisely you're doing the same combat
computation every position but that's
not what's happening in a recurrent
neural network because you have to
worked out the value at position one
before you can start to calculate
value of position - which is used for
the value of position three so this was
a piece of work done by sometimes CS -
24 in co-instructor riches socha and
some of his people at salesforce
research on saying how can we get the
best of both worlds how can we get
something that's kind of like recurrent
neural network but doesn't have the bad
computational properties and so the idea
that they had was well rather than doing
the standard lsdm style thing where
you're calculating you know an updated
candidate value and your gates in terms
of the preceding time slice maybe what
instead we could do is we could stick a
relation between time -1 and time into
the max pooling layer of a convolutional
neural network so we're sort of
calculating a candidate and the forget
gate and an output gate but these these
candidate and the gated values are done
inside the pooling layer via a competent
via convolutional operation so it's sort
of it doesn't it you know if there's no
free lunch you can't get true recurrence
and not pay the penalty this is giving
you sort of a pseudo recurrence because
you're are modeling an association
between adjacent elements at each time
slice but it sort of just worked out
locally rather than being carried
forward in one layer but sort of what
they found is if you made your networks
deeper using this idea well then you
sort of start to again expand your
window of influence so you get a certain
amount of information being carried
forward so their conclusions was that
you could sort of build these kind of
models and get them to work you know not
necessarily better actually on this
slide it says often better you
get them to work kind of as well as an
LS TM does but you could get them to
work much faster because you're avoiding
the standard recurrent operation and
keeping it as something that you can
paralyze in the max pooling operations
yeah so that was a kind of an
interesting alternative way of sort of
trying to get some of the benefits I
think long term this isn't the idea
that's going to end up winning out and
so next week we're going to talk about
transforming networks which actually
seems to be the idea that's getting the
most steam at the moment okay I'll stop
there for today thanks a lot